so what do you paint barry and what are
you making every time berry flies i
would pay barry two thousand dollars a
kilo when he was born five so he had
five uh he made a million dollars each
time and then i had to give him fifty
thousand dollars for the hefe
at mina
you have to give him fifty thousand
dollars said heffy at meena for people
that don't know who the hefty is is this
the william guy i suppose it was he said
i'm having good i'm he totally up i'm
having dinner with the governor tonight
so i don't i don't know i never met the
governor so you never met bill clinton
no no okay i've never even been to mina
but but he told you that this money was
going to bill no he told me i have it
paid away all the way to the top i have
it paid off completely there's no way on
work i can get called mina and he did
say a couple of times i'm gonna be i'm
going to the governor of manchin tonight
now where would you see him what would
you see him oh i saw him all the time i
had to get given him money all the time
but where did you see him all over the
place no i see him in new orleans or
he lived in baton rouge and he'd come to
miami
and i'll tell you a little story he he
wouldn't fly again until i paid him and
it took me about three weeks to get the
pay because it was a pipeline
and so he would barely achieve about it
not being any good-natured really but uh
he's home he one night we went in the
room so he stayed with my wife and i and
the little baby in the in the hotel room
at the omni there and he hold the baby
up on his
big old belly and oh ain't that good rat
and
so uh
i gave him a i paid him a million
dollars and i put a
a package of state free mini pads in
there
and he liked that so good he made a
fought for it on his battlefield let me
ask you a question the story about mina
that
at one point
mina a small city nobody knew about was
getting more ten thousand dollar cash
deposits than any other city in america
was that an accurate story they should
be building banks on top of banks and
the federal government is like why the
hell does mina have so much cash in the
bank there what's going on over here and
it kind of triggered something well i
went to prison and i
was in there for two years and then of
course barry was really nice he he paid
me for the airplanes every penny of it
uh that was and helped my wife
whatever he could got me a lawyer so he
was a good friend of mine very well oh
yeah absolutely i love barry and uh
so then he started uh with the cia those
guys and he was
bringing it up by the tons and he was
landing in the meena and he was taking a
few guns back down can you imagine what
a twin engine plane no matter how big it
is
ak-47 is gonna
affect the war down there
it was just an excuse for them to say
okay we're shipping guns down and
changing for this and
so that's all it was just a front so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]
you